Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nr. 108. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch hier in meinem kleinen Raum, wo es immer so gemütlich ist, um ja einer neuen Ausgabe zu lauschen und heute geht es mal wieder über was vollkommen anderes und zwar soll das Thema heute sein, Schusswaffen. Ja, ihr habt richtig gehört, wir reden über Geballer und Geknaller und hier fliegen die Kugeln tief und da das so ein spezielles Gebiet ist, habe ich mir auch einen Spezialexperten dazu eingeladen und das ist niemand anderes als Pavel. Hallo Pavel. Ja, wir haben gerade festgestellt, dass es schon wieder eine Weile her ist, dass wir eine Sendung gemacht haben.
Ja, wir haben uns auch lange vor diesem Podcast hier gedrückt, weil das Thema natürlich schon so nicht ganz unheikel ist. Ja, wenn man sich, ich sage mal, outet als jemand, der Schießsport betreibt, landet man unter Umständen gleich in so einer bestimmten Ecke, wenn man sagt, okay, ich finde eigentlich Waffen faszinierend und ja, ein interessantes sportliches Betätigungsfeld.
So ist es also. Du findest Schießen interessant. Machst du das ja schon eine Weile seit wann?
Na ja gut, eigentlich seit ich 10 Jahre alt bin, vermutlich mit Luftdruckwaffen, aber dann so richtig sportlich mit Trainingseinsatz und größeren Kalibern. Jetzt, ja wann war das genau? Ja, 1998 eigentlich habe ich etwa angefangen, also gute zehn Jahre jetzt, wo ich mich dann häufiger auf Schießständen rumgetrieben habe.
Mit Luftdruckwaffen hast du angefangen?
Ja.
Also so Luftgewehre?
Ja, hattest du ja Luftgewehre, Luftpistolen, hattest du als Kind sowas nicht?
Nein, hatte ich nicht. Ich bin eigentlich in einer schießfreien Zone aufgewachsen, soweit es mir bekannt war.
Verstehe. Gut, nur heute ist das wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr ganz so, ja, gern gesehen bzw. eigentlich auch dann ohne Aufsicht der Eltern auch verboten, so für Minderjährige mit Luftdruckwaffen zu schießen, aber ja, es ist...
Was hast du denn so aufs Korn genommen?
Das erzähle ich hier jetzt lieber nicht.
Das kommt dann in einem späteren Podcast. Darüber wollen wir eigentlich auch gar nicht reden, sondern wir wollten halt mal reden über das Schießen als solches bzw. Schusswaffen, weil das natürlich auch, abgesehen jetzt von der gesellschaftlichen Diskussion darum, die auch berechtigt ist, natürlich ein technisches Thema ist und technische Themen sind hier zu Hause bei Chaosradio Express. Tja, ich meine, was man immer so assoziiert, denke ich mal, wenn man so an die rauchenden Colts denkt, das ist halt so amerikanische Fernsehserien der Wilde Westen. Alle rennen irgendwie mit einer Knarre durch die Gegend und da wird auch mal schnell einer erschossen, wenn irgendwie was Falsches gesagt hat im Saloon. Und gerade die USA sind ja bekannt als ganz spezielle Waffennahen, die das ja dann sogar in ihrer Verfassung zugesichert bekommen, dass sie welche haben dürfen und benutzen dürfen und so weiter.
Ja, also interessant ist, gut, in den USA gibt es derzeit so nach Schätzungen 200 bis 230 Millionen Schusswaffen auf 300 Millionen Einwohner im privaten Besitz. In Deutschland interessanterweise ist es zwar ein bisschen weniger, aber im privaten Besitz gibt es so ungefähr 10 Millionen Legale und so nach Schätzungen, weil man es nicht weiß, ungefähr 20 Millionen illegale Schusswaffen, die im Umlauf sind. Also in Deutschland...
Das ist eine Schätzung.
Die 20 Millionen ist eine Schätzung. Ich glaube, der Gewerkschaft, der Polizei, so. Aber 10 Millionen in Privatbesitz auf jeden Fall. Also kann man sagen, so jeder Zehnte im Durchschnitt.
Wobei es wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich... Ja, aber der Durchschnitt greift nicht. Ich schätze mal, wer einen hat, der hat auch zwei.
Ja, je nachdem, wie genau es sind.
Also Personenzahlen gibt es in dem Sinne nicht in der offiziellen? Weil Waffen sind doch alle...
Also die, die jetzt registriert sind. Es gibt im Wesentlichen jetzt drei Gruppen privater Waffenbesitzer. Das eine sind Sportschützen, das andere sind Jäger und das dritte Sammler. Also jetzt nicht Pilze-Sammler, sondern Waffensammler, die dann meistens so eine Sammlung geerbt haben und das dann vielleicht weiterführen.
Sportler, Jäger und Sammler und du bist Kategorie 1.
Ja, genau und ja.
Wie ist da so das Verhältnis? Also ich meine, verteilen sich jetzt diese ganzen Waffen im Wesentlichen auf Jäger oder auf Sammler oder auf Sportschützen oder ist das?
Na gut, die Sammler haben natürlich, wenn sie Waffen haben, immer sehr viele davon, weil du natürlich eine bestimmte Mindestmenge brauchst.
Klar, es gibt so viele Sammler, gibt es nicht? Also haben die jetzt die meisten Waffen?
Also das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, aber ich vermute mal, dass sich das zwischen Jägern und Sportschützen sicherlich ganz gut auftaucht. Also es gibt auf jeden Fall mehrere Millionen Haushalte in Deutschland, die auch Waffen zu Hause haben. Also es wird nicht viel drüber geredet, zu Recht teilweise, also es gibt auf jeden Fall in Deutschland deutlich mehr Schusswaffen, als man so glaubt.
Aber es gibt ja relativ starke Vorschriften dafür, wie das erlaubt ist. Also wenn man jetzt eine legalen Waffe besitzt, welche Voraussetzungen muss man denn da für erfüllen?
Ja, zum einen einen Bedarf, also nur weil man irgendwie gerne eine hätte, das reicht nicht aus. Oder beziehungsweise das Bedürfnis. Und das Bedürfnis, dadurch definieren sich eben auch diese drei Besitzgruppen. Entweder als Jäger natürlich, klar, weil mit Pfeil und Bogen darf man in Deutschland keine Tiere erlegen.
Ach echt, das ist verboten?
Ja, in Deutschland ist es verboten mit Pfeil und Bogen. Es gibt Länder, da ist es erlaubt. Es wird gerade diskutiert, weil ich vermute, aus Tierschutz-Erwägungen hat man sich das irgendwann überlegt, dass die Leute vielleicht mit Pfeil und Bogen die Tiere nur verletzen und nicht töten und so, aber das ist das ist gerade.
Da gibt es aber auch so ein bisschen Renaissance gerade, der Bogenschützen, weil mittlerweile ist ja die Technik auch wieder massiv.
Ja, da gibt es gibt es.
Ich erinnere mich an irgendeine Diskussion, ich habe das nur so am Rande mitbekommen.
Ja, da gibt es gerade Diskussionen, aber wie gesagt zum Bedürfnis, also entweder, weil man sich sportlich in dem Bereich betätigt, ist es schon so, dass man sich an eine bestimmte Waffe an deren Eigenheiten gewöhnt, wie dort der Abzug halt geht und wie das Visier ist und deswegen ist es halt, wenn man an Wettbewerben teilnimmt, hat man einfach deutlich bessere Ergebnisse mit einer eigenen Waffe und das ist der Grund, weswegen dann ja die Teilnahme an Wettbewerben so ebenfalls ein Bedürfnis begründet. Und üblicherweise sieht das so aus, dass man, also schon dabei sind, man kann in praktisch allen Schützenvereinen, die sportliches Schießen betreiben, kann man in der Regel auch einfach hingehen und dort sich mit einer Leihwaffe das Ganze erstmal ausprobieren, wie einem das dikt, unter Anleitung. Also dazu braucht man jetzt, sag mal, keine Waffe zu besitzen, um mal schießen zu gehen.
Aber wenn man jetzt eine haben will?
Ja, dann muss man das, ich sag mal, eine Weile machen so. Mindestens sechs Monate, vielleicht auch ein Jahr, einfach den praktischen Umgang, Handhabung.
Also das muss man auch nachweisen.
Ja, das muss man auch nachweisen. Wie weist man das nach? Man führt dann ein Schießbuch, wo man einträgt, wann man trainiert und wie viel Schuss, von welchem Kaliber man verschossen hat. Und das ist dann unter anderem auch die Grundlage, wenn man dann eine Waffenbesitzkarte beantragt. Und daneben gibt es auch noch weitere Bedingungen. Das eine ist dann ja die Sachkunde in Form eines Tests, das man über die Rechtslage und alle möglichen Sicherheitsvorschriften auch Bescheid weiß. Das muss man dann auch im Rahmen einer Prüfung, eine Multiple-Choice-Prüfung, die man dann absolviert bei einem Verein. Und dann gibt es noch das Thema Zuverlässigkeit, wo dann typischerweise das Landeskriminalamt sich dann anschaut, ob man irgendwie Dreck am Stecken hat oder vielleicht dazu neigt, zu etwas impulsiven Verhalten. Also wenn man zum Beispiel mal im Straßenverkehr mit Alkohol auffällig geworden ist oder irgendwelche Dinge, dass er sich mal häufiger geschlagen hat oder irgendjemand bedroht hat oder so, dann kann das auch ein Versagungsgrund sein. Letztendlich gibt es da ein gewisses...
Kennst du da Zahlen darüber, wie häufig so was gewährt oder abgelenkt wird?
Nein, aber wie gesagt, meistens wissen die Leute das wahrscheinlich vorher schon, ob sie eine Chance haben oder nicht. Und dann gibt es noch das Interessante, dass es gab ja mehrere Änderungen. Auch jetzt das Waffengesetz wurde ja mehrfach verschärft. Und vor zehn Jahren habe ich mich noch gewundert, dass die Mitgliedschaft in einer extremistischen Vereinigung gehörte. Zum Beispiel war jetzt kein Grund, eine Waffe zu versagen. Das ist erst vor fünf Jahren etwa reingenommen worden. Nur weil man jetzt politisch...
Was umfasst das? NPD-Mitglieder dürfen keine haben?
Ich glaube, soweit geht es wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber wenn man als rechts- oder linksextremer in Erscheinung getreten ist, war das bis vor ein paar Jahren eben kein Grund.
Kann einem eine Waffenscheinung auch wieder entzogen werden auf der Basis?
Ganz leicht, natürlich auch wegen entweder Zuverlässigkeit. Also wenn man dann tatsächlich betrunken beim Autofahren erwischt wird, kann das ganz leicht dazu führen.
Oder wenn man seine Aufsichtspflicht verletzt hat. Was... bleiben wir doch erstmal bei dem Thema. Also was muss man denn sozusagen dann... Also angenommen hat jetzt diesen Waffenschein sich erarbeitet, also das umfasst, wenn ich es jetzt richtig verstanden habe.
Waffenbesitzkarte ist der richtige Begriff.
Waffenbesitzkarte. Also man muss erstmal in einem Verein üblicherweise, also wahrscheinlich nur in einem Verein, oder in einem Schießsportverein genug geschossen haben. Und dann nachweisen, dass man das getan hat. Und dann muss man diesen Test ablegen. Das macht man aber auch in dem Verein.
Ja, das wird dann meistens organisiert von irgendeinem Verein. Weil in einem Verein sind nie so viele, deswegen macht man das dann meistens.
Cool, aber das wird in Vereinen durchgeführt. Das ist jetzt nicht viel, weil es eine Führerscheinstelle gibt, dass es dann auch eine Waffenbesitzkartenstelle gibt, wo man dann hingeht.
Ja, es gibt dann entsprechend Beauftragte, die den ordnungsgebissenen Verlauf der Prüfung entsprechend beschleunigen und belegen.
Die dann dabei sind.
Die dann die Sachkunde.
Muss man da auch schießen?
Nein, bei der Prüfung nicht.
Warum sind nicht so viele Ringe?
Wie gut man trifft, spielt jetzt keine Rolle. Sehr beruhigend. Allerdings ist es so, dass auf Ständen, wenn man nicht regelmäßig die Scheibe trifft, dass dann irgendwann auch der Standinhaber sagen wird, also Junge, probier es erstmal vielleicht, oder erstmal mit kleineren Kalibern, die hier nicht so viel Schaden verursachen.
Bevor du über unsere Bahnen hier in Schutz und Arsch legst.
Genau.
Gut, wenn man jetzt diese Waffenbesitzkarte hat, dann muss man wahrscheinlich auch Geld für bezahlen, oder?
Ja, ich kann mich nie mehr dran erinnern. Irgendeine Verwaltungsgebühr.
Also nicht substanzielles. Man muss nicht so viel Geld hinlegen, auf jeden Fall, als wenn man jetzt einen Führerschein haben wollte.
Naja, also die Munition, jetzt bei Großkaliberwaffen und die Waffen selbst, sind auch nicht gerade.
Man muss ja jetzt für die Waffenbesitzkarte erstmal noch gar nichts ausgegeben haben.
Genau. Und dann ist wirklich so ein sehr schöner Moment, so wenn man dieses Dokument dann in den Händen hält, hat man da dann bestimmte Voreintragungen für bestimmte Kaliber und dann kann man so in einen Waffenladen gehen und kann sich dann dort einfach Waffen aussuchen. So plötzlich, so die Dinge, die man vielleicht sonst nur so im Katalog oder im Fernsehen sieht, die kann man dann so plötzlich dann in die Hand nehmen und gucken und sich dann ja einfach entscheiden und die Dinge dann mit nach Hause nehmen. Vorausgesetzt natürlich, man hat dann einen ordentlichen Tresor sich auch besorgt, um die wiederum sicher aufzubewahren. Also das kommt auch noch dazu.
Ein Tresor ist Pflicht?
Jaja, unbedingt auch einer bestimmten.
Ja, sag mal, wir müssen jetzt Waffen verwahrt werden. Also wenn man welche besitzen darf, was bedeutet das? Was muss man dann noch an Anforderungen erfüllen, wenn man dann wirklich welche hat?
Naja, wie gesagt, die müssen sicher und für Unbefugte unzugänglich aufbewahrt werden.
Das sichert man aber zu, das muss man nicht nachweisen.
Das Amt hat durchaus das Recht, einen zu besuchen und zu gucken, ob das auch tatsächlich so praktiziert wird.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt auffällig geworden ist, dass sie sich dann denken, da schauen wir noch jemanden an.
Ja, oder wenn irgendjemand sagt, der irgendwie läuft da rum oder seine Kinder spielen irgendwie mit seinen Waffen und das wird irgendwie, ja, spricht sich rum. So, denn ja, kann das sehr schnell passieren, dass mal jemand kommt und guckt.
Also die Dinger sind bei dir im Tresor.
Ja, und ich habe auch nur den einzigen Schlüssel davon. Es gibt auch nur einen Schlüssel und den trage ich immer bei mir. Man kann nie wissen.
Verständlich. Das heißt, das hat dich irgendwie ein halbes Jahr gekostet und dann konntest du dann wieder Terminator reingehen und dann einfach mal auf die Waffen zeigen. Was hast du dir dann gekauft?
Ein Revolver und eine Pistole, das eine. Hier auch ein Smith & Wesson Target-Champion. Das ist so vom Kaliber 357 Magnum. Das war eine neue Waffe. Und dann noch ein recht altes Stück. Das ist so eine Version der SIG P210. Das ist eine Schweizer Waffe. Die, die ich habe, ist glaube ich 40 Jahre alt, als ich sie gekauft habe und war dann im schwedischen Polizeidienst vorher. Das ist auch dieselbe Waffe, die lange Zeit beim Bundesgrenzschutz eingesetzt wurde. Aber bei Sportschützen ist sie einfach deswegen beliebt, weil die sehr gut verarbeitet ist und einfach recht präzise schießt. Ja, die Firma heißt SIG. Ach so, SIG.
Also du hast sozusagen eine normale Pistole und einen Revolver. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen einer Pistole und einem Revolver?
Ja, also ein Revolver hat halt einen Trommel, in den einzelnen Patronen eingeführt werden. Sechs oder sieben Schuss. Und meistens ausschwenkbare Trommel, während eine Pistole über einen Magazin geladen wird. Und dann einen Schlitten und einen Verschluss hat, der über Gasdruck dann nachgeladen wird, wo dann eben die Patronen dann einzeln dem Patronenlager zugeführt werden.
Und auch wieder rausfliegen automatisch.
Und dann die Hülsen dann ausgeworfen werden. Während beim Revolver quasi man sechs oder sieben Patronenlager hat, in denen die Patronen schon liegen, die dann jeweils umgeschwenkt werden.
Und die verbleiben dann und man muss sie dann wieder alle raushauen?
Ja, man muss sie dann auswerfen und wieder ersetzen.
Das heißt der Revolver ist dieser klassische Colt sozusagen? Ist das was von Herrn Colt mal erfunden wurde?
Ja, ob der jetzt der alleinige Erfinder ist. Ich meine, die Geschichte der Waffentechnik ist so vielfältig. Wer dort was, wann, wie erfunden hat, da haben wir ganze Bände.
Wer waren denn die ersten?
Darüber.
War das jetzt wirklich die Chinesen mit ihrem Schießprover oder ist das eigentlich eher so eine industrielle Geschichte, die in Europa losgegangen ist?
Ne, ne, so einzelne Schusswaffen gab es schon, ja, seit es das Schwarzpulver gibt. Und Chinesen aber auch in Europa oder Araber hatten auch schon sehr früh Schießpulver. Man glaubt, dass sogar auch Griechen und Römer sogar schon zum Teil welches hatten. Aber gut, da bin ich sicherlich auch jetzt nicht unbedingt der Geschichtsexperte an der Stelle. Das Einzige, was vielleicht interessant ist, so historisch gesehen, es gab, wo du industrielle Revolution erwähnst, früher so bis zum Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts war es so, dass man Waffen nur herstellen konnte, so Einzelstücke, die dann ein Waffenschmied bearbeitet hat. Und alle Teile einer Waffe waren speziell auf diese Waffe abgestimmt. Auch wenn es das selbe Modell war, konnte man jetzt nicht ein Waffenteil nehmen und in eine andere Waffe einsetzen, weil das dann geklemmt hätte oder nicht wirklich funktioniert und gepasst hätte.
Die Präzision muss schon sehr hoch sein.
Ja, die Präzision muss sehr hoch sein für Waffenteile. Und solange es das nicht wahr war, waren Schusswaffen, gerade auch Handfeuerwaffen und Revolver doch eher Luxusartikel. Das heißt, der Wilde Westen, so wie man das sieht, wo sie alle mit Revolvern im Half darum gelaufen sind, das war nicht so die Quote an Waffenbesitz. Im Wilden Westen war nur ein Bruchteil von dem, was es heute an Waffenbesitz gibt, prozentual. Also rechnet damit, dass vielleicht eine Handfeuerwaffe auf 100 Einwohner kam, dazu dann noch Jagdgewehre in bestimmter Zahl, aber eigentlich waren Waffen im Wilden Westen eher selten, hatten einen großen Seltenheitswert.
Aber das war in den Filmen ganz anders.
Ja, das hat was damit zu tun, dass man natürlich irgendwann, als man die Waffen industriell fertigen konnte, und ein Riesenmarkt entstanden ist, hat man sich natürlich überlegt, wie kann man halt für mehr Absatz sorgen? Und hat dann so ein bisschen dieses Mythos, so jeder Amerikaner braucht eine Waffe, wurde dann auch massiv von der Industrie zum Zwecke der Absatzförderung. Das hat sich dann auch mit der Hilfe von Hollywood natürlich über die Massen gebracht. Also es war auch früher eine Methode von recht erfolgreichem Marketing.
Wenn man die Zahlen jetzt so liest, dann scheint das auch ganz gut funktioniert zu haben.
Ja, wie gesagt 200 bis 230 Millionen Schusswaffen, das ist schon ganz gut.
Sind denn die Aufbewahrungsgesetze in den USA da auch vergleichbar?
Also ich kenne die genaue Rechtslage nicht, aber insgesamt gibt es da, es ist auch von Staat zu Staat sehr verschieden, aber zumindest, was man dann in zeitgenössischen Filmen sieht oder auch hört teilweise, ist, dass Leute doch oft mit der Waffe unter dem Kopfkissen oder im Nachtschränkchen oder sonst wo sie aufbewahren oder sich irgendwo rumliegen haben, wo sie relativ schnell rankommen. Ja, man muss da auch sagen, dass eine Schusswaffe im Haus statistisch gesehen nicht unbedingt die Sicherheit erhöht. Ist das nachweisbar? Ja, es gibt da gewisse Statistiken. Woran das liegt, sind jetzt Dinge, die ich in verschiedenen Büchern, Fachmagazinen gelesen habe. Persönliche Erfahrungen habe ich zum Glück nicht mit. Aber Auseinandersetzungen mit Schusswaffen laufen eben auch meist ganz anders ab, als man das so denkt. Also durchschnittliche Entfernung, irgendwo Schussentfernung bei Handfeuerwaffen liegt bei 80 Zentimetern. Also es wird meistens in großer Nähe passiert das Ganze. Und es geht meistens auch so schnell, wenn es zu einer Auseinandersetzung kommt, dass man auch jetzt zum Beispiel als privater Waffenbesitzer, wenn man seine Waffe im Safe aufbewahrt, vermutlich überhaupt gar keine Gelegenheit hat, auch überhaupt nur dran zu kommen und die zu laden. Also da ist wahrscheinlich längst schon alles vorbei. Also von daher sorgt sie jetzt, wenn man sie nicht schussbereit die ganze Zeit mit sich rumträgt. Aber dann ist es auch so, dass man bei uns im Land... Also ich meine, bist du jemals Zeuge einer Schießerei geworden, so persönlich, im echten Leben?
Nein, bin ich nicht. Allerdings...
Kennst du jemanden?
Ja, ich kenne jemand, der ist erschossen worden. Das ist nämlich mein alter... Also hätte ich Latein gehabt, wäre es mein alter Latein-Lehrer gewesen. Aber die Leute bei uns in der Klasse, die Latein hatten, dieser Latein-Lehrer, der war Zeuge bei einem Banküberfall. Und dann wollte er irgendwie den Helden markieren und ist dann irgendwie dem flüchtenden Bankräuber hinterhergelaufen. Und der hat dann halt tatsächlich auf ihn geschossen. Ob das jetzt irgendwie weniger als 80 Zentimeter waren oder mehr, weiß ich nicht. Vermute mal mehr. Und das ist sicherlich auch sehr unglücklich gelaufen. Auf jeden Fall ist er daran gestorben. Aber das ist natürlich dann auch wieder so diese exzeptionelle Geschichte.
Es sind so Dinge, die einfach zum Glück sehr, sehr selten vorkommen. Und auch, ich sag mal, was man auch merkt, wenn man selbst so Waffen besitzt und damit umgeht, dass das doch eine viel ernstere Angelegenheit ist, als man meinen würde, wenn man das so im Film sieht. Also es fängt erst mal damit an, dass man selbst eine ungeladene Waffe niemals auf irgendeine Person richten würde, weil das einfach extrem unangenehm ist.
Die liegen hier schon ganz bedrohlich.
Also das ist eine extrem unangenehme Erfahrung, allein nur in den Lauf einer ungeladenen Waffe zu blicken.
Das hatte ich auch mal, den Effekt. War ich irgendwann mal irgendwie auf der Straße in Hamburg, und dann kam so ein Verwirrter, und der furtelte damit irgendwas rum. Ob das nun eine richtige Waffe war oder nicht, kann ich in dem Moment gar nicht sagen. Gespann ich nicht, ob die irgendwie geladen war.
Aber ich weiß genau, wovon du redest. Und mit welcher Leichtigkeit in den Filmen Leute nun mit Waffen bedroht werden, und man sich überhaupt gar nichts dabei denkt. Aber allein das ist eigentlich schon eine ungeheure Gewalttat. Selbst wenn man nicht abdrückt, einfach nur eine geladene Waffe auf jemanden zu richten, ist schon brutal. Auf jeden Fall.
Ja, also Filme, das ist natürlich das, was einem als erstes da immer wieder in den Sinn kommt. Das ist doch alles gelogen, oder? Wie in Filmen mit Waffen umgegangen wird, das ist nicht wahr. Ich erinnere mich da auch nur so an diese Soft-Krimis aus den 50er-, 60er-Jahren. Da wird dann mal die Bleispritze aus dem Handtisch hingezogen und piff-paff-puff irgendwie rumgeschossen. Das entbehrt jeglicher Realität.
Also erst mal ist es so, dass die Dinger unglaublich laut sind. Dass man es allein daher schon mal tunlichst vermeiden sollte, sie überhaupt zu benutzen, wenn man nicht unbedingt muss, weil das doch einfach Gehörschäden hervorruft.
Auf dem Schießstand hat man einfach immer solche Kopfhörer, also Lärmschutz auf?
Grundsätzlich immer Lärmschutz, weil der Schallpegel erreicht so 140 bis 170 dBA und das kann einem schlichtweg einfach das Trommelfell zerreißen. Es ist ein einziges Mal passiert, dass ich einen Schuss auf dem Stand abgegeben habe, ohne den Kopfhörer aufzuhaben. Das vergisst man also nicht.
Weil du es vergessen hast?
Ja, weil ich ihn vergessen habe aufzusetzen.
Seitdem vergisst du es aber auch nicht mehr?
Nee, ganz sicher nicht.
In wie vielen Minuten hattest du dann einen Sing und Zwirpen?
Das war ein paar Stunden, das ein enger Stand war, von Beton umgeben, wo das auch noch reflektiert wurde. Und ich habe dann auch den Revolver gemacht, der das größte Getöse.
Die meinen, das sind Polizisten im Einsatz. Ich meine, wenn die jetzt wirklich mal sich genötigt sehen, da zu schießen, müssen wir vorher noch Lärmschutz auftragen?
Sinnvoll wär's, natürlich, seht es nicht. Also mit Pistolen sind auch etwas leiser als Revolver in der Regel, weil da ein bisschen Rückschlagenergie oder der Impuls durch den Schlitten aufnimmt. Also es ist weicher, eine Pistole ist etwas weicher. Und im Freien ist es auch nicht ganz so schlimm wie jetzt in einem geschlossenen Stand. Aber ja, gesund ist es auf jeden Fall nicht, aber man überlebt es. Aber regelmäßig sich Feuergefechte zu liefern würde, also auch zu massiven Hörschäden führen. Und gut, bei Militär hat man dasselbe Problem.
Also so ein durchschnittlicher Action-Movie, wo sie stundenlang durch die Gegend laufen und Peng Peng Peng in alle möglichen Richtungen schießen, kann eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Die Leute werden dann wahrscheinlich die nächsten zwei Tage halb taub. Ja, weil...
Auch so diese lockere Pose, mit der dann normalerweise geschossen wird, mal so eben aus dem Handgelenk.
Ja, das ist...
Haut nicht hin, oder? Ich meine, bei dem Rückstoß?
Ja, gut, der ist unterschiedlich gut beherrschbar. Jetzt bei Pistolen, so bei der 9mm geht das ganz gut, aber bei größeren Magnum-Revolver-Kalibern, also die 357er oder 45er, das ist nichts für jedermann.
Jetzt hast du schon so diverse Fachbegriffe, die man ja auch immer wieder mal hört, aber die glaube ich in der Regel überhaupt keiner so richtig versteht, fallen gelassen. Vielleicht schauen wir uns hier nochmal die, also hier liegen jetzt hier so diese beiden genannten Maschinen, die stehen hier Gott sei Dank magazinfrei, liegen die jetzt hier so rum. Das hier ist jetzt die Pistole, die ich in der Hand heise, du hast gesagt 9 Millimeter. Worauf bezieht sich denn diese Millimeterangabe?
Das ist der Laufdurchmesser bzw. der Geschossdurchmesser. Es gibt da die unterschiedlichsten Numerierungssysteme. Es gibt die amerikanischen, die sich dann auf Zoll beziehen, aber eigentlich auch nicht wirklich. Bei den Amerikanern, bei den Kalibern, ist das mehr so eine Benennung. Es gibt zum Beispiel die 38er Spezial, was man aus alten Detektivfilmen kennt. Die hatten dann sogar einen Film, der irgendwie Punkt 38 Spezial heißt. Das ist aber vom Durchmesser dasselbe wie das Kaliber 357 Magnum. Also 38, 357 und eigentlich entspricht es ungefähr auch einem 9 mm Kaliber. Das heißt, vom Geschossdurchmesser unterscheiden sich halt eine 38er, 357er oder 9 mm kaum. Das ist dann mehr so eine technische Kompatibilitätsnormen. Wie lang dann auch die Patrone ist und das Patronenlager und dass es einfach reinpasst.
Wie viel Luft ist denn da so zwischen dem? Also 9 mm, das hat jetzt sozusagen, hat aber auch wirklich 9 mm Durchmesser jetzt hier. Also das Loch vorne, also 9 mm. Und die Kugel selber, wie viel Spiel hat die da?
Die hat gar kein Spiel, die geht also auch gar nicht, wenn man sie versuchen würde da reinzustecken. Sie ist auch etwas größer. Was aber auch daran liegt, dass die Läufe ja nicht rund sind, sondern typischerweise polygonal bzw. sogenannte Züge drin haben, um die Kugel in Rotation zu versetzen. Also die fällt nicht durch oder so, sondern die wird reingepresst in den Lauf und verformt sich dabei auch ein bisschen und wird dabei in Drehung versetzt. Um im Flug besser stabil zu sein. Um zu vermeiden, dass sich die Kugel dann überschlägt. Irgendwas ist ja keine Kugel, sondern dann länglich.
Sozusagen die Fliehkräfte genauso wie beim Fahrrad.
Ja, die dreht sich dann um ihre eigene Achse und wird dadurch stabilisiert im Flug.
Das heißt, was hast du jetzt gesagt, polygonal? Was heißt das?
Ja, das ist nicht ganz rund, sondern etwas eckig ist der Lauf.
Das heißt, okay, verstehe. Als würde man jetzt so eine Mutter nehmen, so eine Sechskantmutter, während man sie dreht, einmal durchziehen von innen, und dann hätte man die entsprechenden Spuren. Das heißt, die Patrone, in dem Moment, wo sie abgefeuert wird und durch den Lauf durchgepresst wird, passt dann einfach durch, weil sie einfach so viel Energie hat, schiebt sich sozusagen. Deswegen hat man auch diese Spuren dann immer wieder beim Lauf, und deswegen kann man auch immer genau erkennen, welche Kugel aus welcher Pistole abgefeuert wurde.
Ja, da gibt es eine ganze Menge Spuren. Das sollte man übrigens nicht tun, so den Hahn. Gut, das ist ein Schweizer Präzisionsprodukt, aber auch das tut man nicht, einfach den Lauf leer, wenn unter dem Hammer so kein Zündhütchen liegt, was so den Schlag des Hammers abbremst. Das ist nicht schlimm, aber man tut es nicht, als sorgfältiger Waffenbesitzer einfach leer abziehen, sondern man entspannt ihn halt dann wieder.
Wie entspanne ich ihn?
Du löst aus und hältst ihn dabei fest.
Vielleicht können wir noch mal genauer erklären, wie schießt denn so ein Ding jetzt eigentlich? Was bringt die Patrone tatsächlich zum Fliegen?
Das ist schon sehr spannend. Eine Pistole ist technisch gesehen eine Wärmekraftmaschine. So wie das Auto auch. Es gibt da auch eine gewisse Verwandtschaft zum Motorsport. Viele der Fachbücher kommen auch aus dem Motorbuchverlag. Da gibt es auch eine gewisse Verwandtschaft.
Verwandtschaft in der Affinität?
In der Affinität und der Technik. Und Wärmekraftmaschinen.
Da geht es ja auch um Explosionen.
Explosionen und brütierende Metalle. Was jetzt konkret passiert, man weiß natürlich, es gibt dort die Treibladung. Eine Patrone besteht vorne aus dem Geschoss. Dann die Hülse, die die Treibladung enthält. Das ist sogenanntes Nitropulver. Also entweder Nitroglycerin oder Nitrozylulose, die da drin ist. Und dann entsprechend hinten noch ein Zündhütchen, was einen schlagempfindlichen Stoff enthält, der dann diese Nitroladung entzündet. Und die entzündet, also die enthält doch eine ganze Menge Energie. Und man muss sich das so vorstellen, dass wenn wir jetzt etwa den Revolver nehmen, dass dann für, also in einem Bruchteil einer Millisekunde verbrennt das Ganze und es entsteht einen Druck von 3200 Bar etwa. Das ist sehr ordentlich.
Noch mal kurz hier, bevor wir da weiter marschieren. Also diese Patrone hat halt so diese typische Patronenform, das kennt man ja schon, und nur der vordere Teil ist jetzt die Kugel. Aber die Kugel an sich ist nicht rund, sondern die ist eher wie so eine Rakete.
Ja, die kann alle möglichen Formen haben. Die kann zylinderförmig sein, die kann hier so ein bisschen parabolisch geformt sein. Also da gibt es alle möglichen Formen, Spitz.
Okay, und hinten ist halt die Kappe drauf und dieser Auslöser. Und wenn ich jetzt die Pistole abziehe, dann schlägt dieser Spanner, den man ja so, also den man, indem ich nur drücke, wird er ja automatisch nach hinten gepresst, aber man kann auch vorspannen. Macht man das in der Regel?
Beim Revolver, beim sportlichen Schießen ja. Das nennt sich dann das sogenannte Single Action Schießen. Trifft jetzt auf den Revolver zu, spannt man jetzt den Hahn mit dem Auslöser hier. Dann muss man wesentlich mehr Kraft aufwenden. So etwa bis zu 8 Kilo muss der Finger stemmen, wenn man hier den Hahn mitspannen will. Das nennt sich dann das sogenannte Double Action Schießen. Macht man aber in Deutschland beim sportlichen Schießen praktisch nicht, sondern da spannt man den Hahn immer mit dem Daumen vor. So und löst dann aus. In den USA gibt es aber auch Wettbewerbe im Double Action Schießen. Normalerweise, um jetzt mal die Vorgänge zu illustrieren, wenn man jetzt den Abzug betätigt, so dauert es etwa die Auslösezeit. Liegt so bei 3 bis 10 Millisekunden je nach Pistolen-Typ, die es braucht, von dem Moment, wo man den Abzugshahn betätigt, bis dann der Hahn aufschlägt und die Patrone zündet.
Wieso zündet die sich? Dieser Schlag, was tut der? Mischt der dann irgendwas miteinander? Oder ist das einfach die Reibungsenergie?
Da ist einfach ein Material drin, was sich einfach auf Schlag entzündet durch die innere Reibung.
Das tut es auch zuverlässig? Dass mal eine nicht losgeht, ist selten?
Das ist ganz selten. Bei den größeren Kalibern ist bei den einige Zehntausend Schuss abgegeben. Bei größeren Kalibern ist mir das nur ein einziges Mal passiert.
Was ist denn jetzt größeres Kaliber? Also was ist das Kleinkaliber, was ist das Großes?
Also von Kleinkaliber spricht man halt so bis 5 mm Geschoss- oder Laufdurchmesser. Und alles, was danach kommt, drüber liegt, sind dann halt größere Kaliber.
Also wir haben hier ein großes Kaliber sozusagen auf dem Tisch. Die beiden 9 mm eigentlich?
Ja, wie gesagt 3,759 und 9 mm ist ungefähr dasselbe.
Achso, das eine ist Zoll, das andere ist Millimeter, alles klar. Gut, das heißt der Hahn stößt jetzt auf, jetzt wird das entzündet und dann?
Ja, und dann entzündet sich halt dieses Nitropulver und expandiert erzeugt einen gewaltigen Gasdruck.
3200 Bar, was hat man so in seinem Fahrrad?
Naja, vier, fünf. Genau, also das ist schon gewaltiger Druck. Also hier bei der Pistole, bei der 9 mm Para sind es nur 2600 Bar, also die hat halt ein bisschen weniger. Dann ist es so, dass das Geschoss sich dann auch sehr schnell in Bewegung setzt, durch den Lauf getrieben wird. Und typischerweise, nach spätestens einer Millisekunde hat das Geschoss dann die Waffe auch bereits verlassen. Also es ist so, dass die Zeit, bis der Hahn auftrifft, um ein Vielfaches länger ist als das, was danach passiert, wenn sich das Geschoss...
In dem Moment trennt sich jetzt sozusagen der Frontteil von der Hülse und wird dann durch diese nicht runde Laufform schon in Rotation gebracht und verlässt den Lauf selbst rotierend nach vorne. Im Idealfall.
Und was auch noch vielleicht interessant ist, die Leistung, also wenn man es in Watt ungefähr misst, die dann innerhalb dieser Millisekunde, in der die beschleunigt wird, liegt bei der kleinen hier, bei der 9, was heißt klein, bei der Pistole so etwa bei 700 Kilowatt und bei der 357 etwa bei 1000 Kilowatt für eine Millisekunde. Das heißt, für eine Millisekunde 1 Megawatt an Energie freigesetzt. Das ist schon heftig. Also ja, deswegen, ja, also auch schon durchaus mehr so ein Männerspielzeug, hat 1000 PS, die man da mal eben freisetzt, wenn auch nur für einen kurzen Moment. Das macht sicherlich auch Faszination aus von so großen, mit so größeren Kalibern.
Wonach richtet sich jetzt dieser Rückstoß?
Ja, der richtet sich, okay, es gibt jetzt den objektiven Rückstoß und den gefühlten objektiv, hat das was mit dem Gewicht der Waffe zu tun und der Größe der Ladung und dem Gewicht der Patrone. So, das sind die Dinge, die objektiv eine Rolle spielen. Subjektiv spielt die größte Rolle die Beschaffenheit des Griffstücks, weil dieselbe Waffe mit unterschiedlichem Griff abgefeuert, erzeugt subjektiv ganz andere Arten von Stößen in der Hand. Aber was da ziemlich faszinierend ist beim Thema Rückstoß, dass offenbar die Naturgesetze dieses Universums so beschaffen sind, dass sie die Existenz oder das Abfeuern von Schusswaffen extrem begünstigen. Und zwar das, was erstmal nicht ganz intuitiv zu verstehen ist. Was ich mich lange Zeit gefragt habe, man stelle sich vor jemanden, der eine Waffe abfeuert und dem steht jemand gegenüber, der mit einer anderen Waffe die Patrone auffängt, die ihm entgegenkommt. Also in den Lauf schießt. Genau, jetzt schießt einer dem anderen gewissermaßen in den Lauf. Jetzt müsste man ja denken, gut, der eine feuert die Kugel ab mit einem gewissen Schwung, der andere fängt sie auf. Eigentlich müsste ja irgendwie der Stoß, den jetzt beide empfinden, gleich sein. Oder was würdest du denken? Ich meine, beide haben eine Waffe, die eine feuert sie ab, der andere fängt sie auf, die ist gleich schwer.
Nein, ich würde das nicht denken, dass der gleich ist. Ich würde denken, dass der auftreffende Stoß doch extrem viel stärker ist.
Und warum?
Das versuche ich auch gerade zu ergründen, warum ich das eigentlich denke.
Du hast recht.
Weil in dem Moment, wo es sich löst, geht ja die eigentliche Energie nach vorne weg. Also ich habe ja im Rückstoß nicht die Energie, die wirklich freigesetzt wird. Während wenn ich das Ding empfange, kriege ich ja die volle Energie.
Ja, allerdings ist, du hast da intuitiv recht.
Aber ich habe es nicht gut begründet.
Naja, was heißt begründet? Also intuitiv vom Gefühl her hast du recht. Es gibt aber da auch einen sehr schönen Grund. Also zunächst mal gilt ja der Impulserhaltungssatz. Also nach dem Abfeuern, also Impulserhaltungssatz heißt, dass wenn sich jetzt zwei Dinge voneinander trennen, dass der Gesamtimpuls gleich bleibt, in dem Fall gleich Null. Das heißt, und Impuls ist Basse mal Geschwindigkeit. Das heißt, die Masse der Kugel, weil die Geschwindigkeit der Kugel ist genauso groß mit negativen Vorzeichen, wie die Geschwindigkeit der Waffe und das Gewicht der Waffe nach dem Abfeuern. Also so eine Kugel, das mal zu illustrieren, wiegt so zwischen 4 und 9 Gramm. Eine Waffe wiegt so typischerweise hier, also der Revolver wiegt etwa 1,3 Kilogramm. Das heißt, man hat ein Verhältnis, bzw. die Waffe für den Revolver sind so 6 bis, die Pistole für den Revolver sind 6 bis, ja, die Kugel, das Geschoss wiegt so 6 bis 13 Gramm. Also die Waffe ist so 100 bis 200 Mal schwerer als das Geschoss, das man abfeuert. Das heißt, dass die Geschwindigkeit, mit der die Kugel den Lauf verlässt, eben auch 100 bis 200 Mal so hoch ist, wie die Geschwindigkeit, mit der sich die Waffe dann auf dich zu bewegt beim Rückstoß. Das heißt aber immer noch, weil das Geschoss, so wie jetzt beim Revolver, zwischen 350 bis 600 Metern pro Sekunde fliegt, bewegt sich die Waffe dann trotzdem auch noch mit 3 Metern pro Sekunde ungefähr in die andere Richtung. Wird natürlich schnell dann von der Hand aufgefangen. Das Entscheidende ist jetzt aber, das eine ist der Impuls-Erhaltungssatz, wo die beiden proportional zueinander sind. Wenn man aber jetzt die Energie berechnen möchte, die Energie, die nach dem Schuss in der Pistole und die Energie, die nach dem Schuss im Geschoss sitzt, die Energie geht ja Masse mal Geschwindigkeit zum Quadrat. Das heißt, weil die Kugel so schnell wie möglich viel schneller ist, trägt sie das hundertfache an Energie wie die Pistole. Das ist halt das absolut Verrückte. Das heißt, jemand, der jetzt die Kugel auffangen würde, würde von der Energie, die die Explosion verursacht hatte, etwa das hundertfache abbekommen, wie derjenige, der die Waffe abfeuert.
Bis 200-facher.
Ja, 100- bis 200-facher. Das heißt, das Verrückte ist, dass beim Abfeuern einer Waffe der Großteil der Energie...
Sonst könnte man ja auch Leute nicht wirklich damit erschießen. Oder alle Leute würden sich dann auch gleich durchs Schießen schon erschießen, wenn das nicht so wäre. Ich meine, wenn das Ding so eiert, und wenn das irgendwie auch alles nicht so rund ist, und jede kleinste Unebenheit spielt ja da, glaube ich, eine Rolle, wie fliegt denn diese Kugel dann eigentlich? Wie nennt man das? Ballistik, oder?
Ja, genau. Also das ist dann die sogenannte äußere Ballistik. Das, was wir gerade vorher beschrieben hatten, das, was in der Pistole passiert, war die sogenannte innere Ballistik. Und dann gibt es halt noch die Zielballistik. Aber wenn wir mal bei der äußeren Ballistik bleiben, die fliegt halt, wie man auch weiß, eine Parabel. Wobei bei den Entfernungen, also beim sportlichen Schießen mit Handfeuerwaffen schießt man meistens auf 25 Metern Entfernung. Und da ist jetzt der Weg, den die Kugel durchsackt, minimal, der bewegt sich irgendwie im Subzentimeterbereich. Also praktisch kann man sagen, fliegt die Kugel die ersten 25 Meter fast gerade. Und wenn man Zeit hat, genau genug zu zielen, trifft man auch erstaunlich genau mit so einer Pistole. Das unterschätzen halt wiederum die Filme meistens, wie genau man jetzt tatsächlich auf unbewegliche Ziele wie Zielscheiben schießen kann. Auf 25 Meter Entfernung schafft man es, wenn man etwas geübt ist, praktisch alle Schüsse in einem Kreis von zehn Zentimetern unterzubringen. Vielleicht von 50 Schuss gehen dann ein, zwei außerhalb dieses zehn Zentimeter Durchmesserkreises.
Um jetzt zum Beispiel so einen Menschen zu verfehlen, auf diese Distanz muss man sich schon richtig anstrengen.
Ja, das ist also mit Zielen gut. Es ist nun so, dass es einen riesen Unterschied gibt. Die Psychologie macht da auch einen riesen Unterschied. Das merkt man dann auch an dem Unterschied alleine nur zwischen den Ergebnissen, die man im Training erzielt und wenn man dann im Wettbewerb steht, wo dann doch ein Druck da ist, ist es gleich schon deutlich schwieriger, an die Trainingsergebnisse ranzukommen. Also es ist beim Schießen zum Teil genau umgekehrt wie bei anderen Sportarten, wo dann durch das Adrenalin man eher beflügelt wird. So bei körperlicher Anstrengung ist es beim Schießsport eher gegenteilig, dass das Adrenalin eher hinderlich ist fürs Schießen und umso. Problematischer ist es natürlich in Situationen, wo man vielleicht tatsächlich eine Waffe einsetzen muss. Da ist es natürlich noch schwieriger, einfach die Ruhe zu bewahren. Aber wenn man dazu in der Lage ist, kann man eben auch durchaus auf 50 oder 100 Metern noch gut treffen.
Ist das so der Grund, warum dich das überhaupt so gereizt hat? Dass man dann so zähnmäßig da rumstehen muss? Wie weit geht denn das?
Muss man da irgendwie meditieren? Zunächst hat mich diese mächtige Wärmekraftmaschine gereizt und dieses Mythos, was natürlich auch das Ganze umgibt. Aber dann war es tatsächlich so, dass das extrem beruhigend wirkt. Es ist auch eine Art von Meditation. Es gibt sicherlich etwas ruhigere Arten zu meditieren. Aber dadurch, dass man jetzt bei so einem Trainingslauf, wo man dann 50 oder 100 Schuss abgibt, immer von extremer Konzentration wechselt. Dann löst sich der Schuss, entspannt sich dann wieder die Anspannung, Entspannung. Spätestens nach 10, 15 Schuss hat man einfach alles vergessen, weil man immer diese Konzentration und Entspannungszyklen hat. Das war auch das, warum ich mich dann so dafür begeistert habe. Und dann fast eine Zeit lang jeden Tag nach der Arbeit eine Stunde zum Entspannen auf den Schießstand um, halt einfach dann wieder völlig relaxt.
Die Arbeit war so anstrengend, jetzt muss ich erstmal eine Runde ballern gehen.
Ja, aber es ist eher das Gegenteil, also es baut keine Aggressionen auf, sondern eher ab.
Auf deinem Revolver prangt hier auch noch so ein Etikett oder mehrere übereinander?
Ja, das ist jeweils bei den entsprechenden Meisterschaften. Bevor man mit der Waffe schießen darf, werden im Wesentlichen zwei Dinge überprüft. Einmal das sogenannte Abzugsgewicht. Man kann die Waffen in Abzug beliebig leicht machen, aber es gibt in der Sportordnung dann vorgeschrieben, dass es in der bestimmten Klasse eine Waffe, ein bestimmtes Abzugsgewicht haben muss. Das heißt, da wird dann die Waffe genommen, da gibt es dann ein Gewicht mit einem Draht, der wird dann drangehängt und dann wird geguckt, ob der...
Man hält die Pistole so senkrecht hin und dann...
Ja, dann hängt man Gewicht einfach an den Haaren und das muss der halten, ohne dass die auslöst. Das ist so das eine Ding. Und dann wird noch die Pistole zusammen mit der Munition, braucht man dann auch einen bestimmten Mindestimpuls, weil sonst könnte man sicher wieder Munition machen, die nicht so schnell fliegt und mit einem schwächeren Rückstoß und hätte dann auch bestimmte Vorteile. Und da wird dann eben auch noch gemessen, ob die Waffe mit der Munition dann auf die Patrone gewogen und da wird gemessen, wie schnell sie die Pistole verlassen hat. Und daraus wird dann berechnet, ob der Mindestimpuls gegeben ist. Da gibt es Geräte. Ja, es gibt welche mit Licht und mit Schall. Und die messen das halt. Das sind dann Gatter und die zählen einfach.
Die messen die Austrittsgeschwindigkeit?
Ja, beziehungsweise meistens einen Meter vor der Mündung ungefähr die Geschwindigkeit, mit der dann ein bestimmter Bereich durchflogen wird.
Und das darf dann nicht zu was?
Nein, die muss dann schnell genug sein im Verhältnis zum Geschossgewicht. Also eine schwere Kugel muss nicht so schnell sein wie eine leichte, aber Zusammenhalt. Also Geschossgewicht und Geschwindigkeit müssen einen bestimmten Wert ergeben, damit du halt...
Das heißt, bevor so ein Wettbewerb losgeht, wird das Ding einmal so getestet, wie du es jetzt gesagt hast. Es wird halt auch mal geschossen. Aber sozusagen exemplarisch wird dann aus deinem Patronsatz ein paar Testkugeln rausgenommen, sozusagen random.
Ja, wobei das halt... Also wenn man Fabrikmunition benutzt, wird da zum Teil darauf verzichtet. Man kann aber auch Munition selbst laden oder herstellen. Das ist dann auch noch ein weiterer Schein, den man dann machen kann. Das macht die ganze Sache dann ein bisschen preiswerter und so. Man kann dann auch noch ein bisschen mehr mit unterschiedlichen Pulvern und Kugeln und kann dann auch noch etwas präziser die Munition machen als bei Fabrik-Munition.
Das heißt, der Schießner sitzt tatsächlich da und mischt sich so sein eigenes Schießpulver?
Ja, sein eigenes Schießpulver nicht direkt, aber es gibt dann ungefähr 50 bis 100 verschiedene Pulversorten, unter denen er dann auswählt und vielleicht sogar Sorten mischt und dann extrem genau abwiegt. Also das ist natürlich der Schlüssel, dass die Pulvermenge, die halt bei Fabrikmunitionen dann doch gewissen Schwankungen unterworfen ist, dass man da dann ganz präzise die Pulvermenge abwiegt.
Gibt es dann sozusagen die Patronen auch ohne Schießpulver zu kaufen? Oder nimmt man die auseinander?
Also es gibt die zum einen komplett in allen Einzelteilen zu kaufen, also sowohl die Zündhütchen gibt es einzeln, dann die Hülsen als auch das Geschoss, wobei man die Geschosse auch noch selber fertigen kann aus Blei. Kann man die auch aus Bleigießen oder pressen.
Das nutzen dann alle so mit so einem Zinnlöffel.
Die Hülsen kann man wieder verwenden. Also da werden auch gerne dann von bestimmten Kalibern nach dem Schießen halt die Hülsen wieder eingesammelt. Die überstehen erst so unbeschadet? Die kann man ein paar Mal benutzen, die Hülsen. Irgendwann werden sie dann halt ein bisschen spröde, aber grundsätzlich sind die durchaus wiederverwendbar.
Ist das dann eine Gefahr, wenn die zu spröde sind?
Was würde dann passieren?
Kann es sein, dass die so eine Explosion auf eine Art und Weise löst, dass die Kugel nicht rauskommt?
Eigentlich nicht. Die Hülse muss ja nicht wirklich den Druck aufnehmen, weil sie ja in dem sogenannten Patronenlager sitzt. Die ist ja umhüllt von dem eigentlichen Teil des Laufs, wenn man so will. Das heißt, da dehnt sie sich etwas aus und drückt dann dagegen. Wer halt ein bisschen mehr abkönnen muss, ist so dieser Patronenboden. Da ist dann etwas mehr Druck. Aber grundsätzlich sind die schon extrem zuverlässig.
Was heißt denn dieses Magnum?
Das heißt im Wesentlichen, dass die Patrone etwas länger ist und ein bisschen mehr Pulver drin hat.
Genauso wie bei einer Shampoos-Flasche. Einfach ein bisschen größer.
In dem Fall ein bisschen länger. Also nicht größer, sondern länger. Meistens oder mehr, beziehungsweise mehr Pulver. Der Durchmesser über das Kaliber selbst sagt es nichts aus. Also ich hatte ja vorhin schon gesagt, die 357er und 38 Spezial ist dasselbe Kaliber. Nur die 357 Magnum hat halt mehr Pulver drin. Man kann eben auch in dem 357er 38 Spezial-Munition verschießen.
Die ja noch mehr Wumm hat?
Nee, weniger.
Weniger Wumm hat? Also Spezial versus Magnum.
Ja, genau.
Warum Spezial weniger ist, weißt du nicht.
Das ist alles Branding, Marketing.
Na wenn es schon weniger Wumm hat, dann muss es zumindest toll klingen.
Das war das Kaliber-Spezial, 38 Spezial ist das ältere Kaliber. Das gab es, glaube ich, vorher und dann hat man noch etwas draufgesattelt.
Dieser Alltag in so einem Schießverein. Ich meine, diese Schießvereine sind ja üblicherweise selten, keine Ahnung, es mag welche geben, die bauen sich jetzt ihre Schießstände komplett selber. Aber ich glaube in Berlin ist es häufig anzutreffen, dass die so in alten Bunkern untergebracht sind.
Ja, das gibt es durchaus auch zumindest. Mein Verein hat das mit großem Aufwand in Tempelhof sich einen Bunker umgebaut. Wobei es also Schießstätten, die meisten Schießstätten, sind schon irgendwo überirdisch oder in Hallen oder in Gebäuden unterschiedlich gut ausgestattet. So gibt es riesige Unterschiede, je nachdem ob man auch Scheibenzuganlagen hat oder tatsächlich nach vorne laufen muss und dann von Hand die Löcher zukleben. Generell trifft man beim Schießsport schon relativ wenig junge Leute an. Die meisten sind jenseits der 50 eher. Das Durchschnittsalter ist doch recht hoch. Dann gibt es ein bisschen Nachwuchs. Es mag sein, dass es in anderen Gegenden vielleicht anders ist, aber generell ist es jetzt nicht unbedingt die Trendsportart. Man hat schon eher so etwas wie Nachwuchsprobleme. Frauenanteil auch sehr gering, geringer als bei den Informatikern. Dann erstaunlicherweise doch ein recht hoher Ausländeranteil bei den Sportschützen.
Schließt du jetzt von Berlin da auf?
Ja, also das, was ich jetzt so in Berlin einfach...
Was meinst du mit hoher Ausländer? Also hoch im Verhältnis zum Ausländeranteil der Bevölkerung, die wir hier haben, oder hoch im Sinne zu anderen Sportarten?
Ja, also hoch im Verhältnis zu meiner Erwartung, zu dem, was ich...
Das ist natürlich sehr relativ. Was hast du erwartet?
Eigentlich dachte ich, dass es eher so eine deutsche Traditionsveranstaltung ist, und genauso ein bisschen so man ist unter sich, ist auch, ich sag mal, zum Teil so. Wobei die Leute, also man findet dort sehr viel, auch technisch interessierte Leute, die auch andere Nerd-Hobbies, also Amateur-Funker, sehr viele Autoschrauber, auch dabei. Also ja, es sind schon Technik, also viele technikaffine Leute, die man findet. Aber dann eben auch doch eine recht hohe Zahl, speziell was mir aufgefallen ist in Berlin, viele Türken, viele Leute aus den ehemaligen jugoslawischen Ländern, viele Leute, die aus Russland gekommen sind. Also die stellen jetzt genau, was so den Nachwuchs angeht. Oder bei den jüngeren Leuten sind die halt einfach sehr stark vertreten, habe ich das Gefühl, weil die vermutlich auch ein etwas entspannteres Verhältnis oder ein anderes Verhältnis zu dem Thema haben als typischer in Deutschland sozialisierter Jugendlicher, wo Waffen einfach böse sind und nur zum Leute umbringen. Und man ansonsten auch halber Faschist ist, wenn man sich für Schießsport interessiert.
Ich war einmal mit dir da und ich hatte auch nicht das Gefühl, in so ein Terror-Ausbildungslager zu kommen. Das war dann doch sehr bodenständig. Da hat es dann schon noch ein bisschen was von Kegelklub gehabt. Da hat man dann den Chef vom Verein oder wie viele Personen da eine Rolle spielen, die dann halt da wahrscheinlich fast immer sind in dem Bunker. Und dann sitzt man da halt und redet nett. Dann geht man halt ab und zu mal raus und schießt sich mal wieder ein. Vielleicht sollte man diesen Eindruck noch mal ein bisschen vermitteln. Also man kommt halt so rein, meldet sich an, man kennt einen, muss man sich da irgendwie immer ausweisen. Du hast ja ein Buch, wo drin steht, was du geschossen hast.
Wer füllt das aus? Das persönliche Schießbuch füllt man selbst aus und lässt dann entsprechend abstempeln. Zum anderen gibt es natürlich noch, muss man sich dort auch im Verein nur innerlich eintragen, allein schon aus versicherungstechnischen Gründen muss man sich dann vorm Schießen ein- und austragen.
Das heißt, diese Vereine sind auch pauschal versichert?
Und man ist auch als Vereinsmitglied nochmal über den Dachverband versichert. Aber es ist alles in allem, wird schon sehr, war mein Eindruck, sehr sicher mit Waffen umgegangen. Also ich hab's jetzt nicht erlebt in der ganzen Zeit, das mag sicherlich mal vorkommen, aber dass sich jemand verletzt hätte sowieso nicht und dass sich irgendwo mal versehentlich einen Schuss gelöst hätte bei jemandem. Also eine gefährliche Situation in dem Sinne hab ich in den zehn Jahren Schießsport jetzt nicht erlebt. Weil es auch so ist, dass natürlich jeder extrem drauf achtet und man ganz schnell was auf die Finger kriegt oder vom Stand geschmissen wird, wenn man irgendwie anfängt, da jetzt Späßken zu machen. Dann kann man eigentlich gleich nach Hause gehen. Also das ist schon eine ernste Geschichte.
So, wenn man auf so einem Schießstand marschiert, das ist ja so eine lange Röhre und ja.
In dem Fall, es gibt halt auch Schießstände, also die im Freien sind, dann hat man irgendwie ein Feld dahinter.
Aber wenn es indoor ist, ist es schon... Es ist auf jeden Fall auf irgendeine Form gesichert, dass einem jetzt nicht mal eben ein Reh oder sonst irgendwie ein Fußgänger jetzt vor die Flinte läuft. In dem Fall war es halt so ein langer Tunnel. Auf jeden Fall hat man auf 25 Meter Distanz dann das Ziel. Das ist eben das, was man so denkt, eben so dieses Zielscheibe, die in dem Fall, du hast vorhin schon den Begriff gesagt, wie heißt das so schön, wenn man es nach vorne ziehen kann, eine Schlitten...
Ja, eine Scheibenzuganlage.
Eine Scheibenzuganlage. Das heißt, man kann da irgendwie auf den Knopf drücken, dann kommt das Ding irgendwie zu einem gefahren, da sind da oben ein paar Clips dran, da kann man dann eben seine Zielscheibe, die holt man sich vorher in der Theke ab, klemmt die da rein, dann hängt die da dran, drückt man nochmal auf den Knopf, dann macht das Ding ein paar Sekunden wieder hinten. So, und dann geht's los. Wie bereitet man sich jetzt vor? Also wir wollen jetzt mal irgendwie schießen. Vielleicht kannst du mal so diese Schritte und auch so diese Sicherheitsschritte, die man dabei berücksichtigen muss, noch mal darstellen.
Zum einen ist es so, dass man niemals mit der geladenen Waffe dort auf dem Schießstand herumläuft. Damit fängt es schon mal an. Sondern man packt halt die Waffe aus. Beim Revolver schwenkt man dann die Trommel aus und legt die halt vor sich ab, so mit dem Lauf Richtung Zielscheibe. Das hat einfach mehrere Gründe. Zum einen, dass der Schießnachbar sehen kann, also beruhigt ist und sieht, okay, die ist jetzt nicht geladen. Und bei der Pistole legt man halt auch die Pistole ab und dann das Magazin daneben, stellt dann seine Munition dort ab. Und ja, vorher natürlich, wie gesagt, hat man natürlich schon seinen Hörschutz aufgesetzt.
Das habt ihr jetzt schon wieder vergessen.
Sollte, genau. Und packt dann außerdem vielleicht noch so sein Fernrohr aus, mit dem man eventuell kontrolliert nach jedem Schuss.
Also man schießt nicht mit dem Zielfernrohr, sondern...
Nee, sondern man guckt, wo der Schuss hingegangen ist, unter Umständen.
Es sei denn, man kann natürlich auch diese Zielscheibe dann wieder mit dem Knopf nach vorne holen, oder man so einen Schlitten hat.
Ja, aber wenn man das nach jedem Schuss wissen will, dann stellt man sich halt noch ein Fernrohr hin. Ja, und gut, dann gibt es halt den Unterschied, je nachdem, wenn man auf einem Stand mit einer Scheibenzuganlage ist, holt man die jeweils entsprechend ran. In einem anderen Fall, jetzt auf offenen Ständen oder auf Ständen ohne Scheibenzuganlage, da kommt dem Schießleiter noch eine besondere Rolle zu. Der muss nämlich dafür sorgen, dass niemand nach vorne geht zur Scheibe, solange nicht alle ihre Waffen sicher und entladen abgelegt haben. Weil da läuft es so, dass dann bei den Wettbewerben dann auch meist so, da wird dann geschossen, alle legen ab und dann erst, wenn halt Sicherheit besteht, gehen dann alle gemeinsam nach vorne zu den Scheiben und gehen dann wieder nach hinten. Und erst, wenn dann wieder auch alle den Gefahrenbereich verlassen haben, darf man auch wieder überhaupt seine Waffe berühren. Also wenn man irgendwie während dort sich Leute vorne bewegen, auch nur seine Waffe anfasst, das gibt Riesenerger.
Also man muss auch sagen, Sicherheit ist Trumpf. Ich hatte auch so den Eindruck, dass einfach jeder Schritt, der gemacht wird, ist einfach immer so mit doppeltem Witz und Boden.
Du hast halt dort diese 3000 Bar und dieses eine Megawatt, was nur darauf wartet, loszuschlagen. Also man stelle sich eine gewaltige, gespannte Feder vor, die irgendwie jederzeit los schnacken kann. Und da geht man einfach vorsichtig mit um. Und die andere Sache ist wirklich auch so ein interessanter Effekt, wenn halt viele Leute dabei sind, die nun Waffen tragen. Das führt interessanterweise auch dazu, dass man höflicher miteinander umgeht.
Da macht man nicht mal so einen Spruch.
Interessanter Effekt. Ja, also man prollt halt nicht so rum, sondern alle sind halt so ein. Man rennt nicht jemanden an oder irgendwie du Arsch. Das hat man halt eher selten. Aber nochmal gut, um das nochmal abzuschließen. Meistens, je nach Wettbewerb, bei meinen meisten Wettbewerben beim sportlichen Schießen lädt man immer nur 5 Schuss. So entweder beim Revolver, weil die meisten 6-schüssig sind, lässt man halt eine Kammer frei oder zwei, je nach Typ. Und beim Magazin lädt man eben auch nicht, dass ein Magazin voll bis oben hin, sondern eben auch nur 5 Schuss. Nimmt dann entsprechend die Waffe auf und lädt sie, schießt, also gibt diese 5 Schuss ab, auch mit ordentlich Schießen.
Moment, bevor man schießt, muss man erzielen. Und man muss sie halten.
Ja, okay, wenn man gut da ist, ist richtig, also mit dem Zielen, dass man halt weiß, wie ein ordentliches Visierbild aussieht, ist gut, wie kann man das beschreiben? Im Prinzip Kimme und Korn, also das Korn muss auf derselben Höhe.
Also Korn ist die Spitze vorne.
Ja, und Korn ist die...
Und Kimme ist das mit dem Loch in der Mitte.
Ja, es ist so ein Schlitz.
Genau.
Und...
Die bringt man dann auf sozusagen so hin, dass das Korn in der Mitte von der Kimme ist.
Ja, und zwar auf selber Höhe, dass die Oberkante vom Korn auf derselben Höhe ist, wie die Oberkante der Kimme. Und dann gibt es halt rechts und links noch einen Spalt, den man dann natürlich sieht, weil das Korn etwas kleiner ist. Und da achtet man darauf, dass dieser Spalt rechts und links gleich groß ist. Und dann gibt es auch wieder, also normalerweise bei den meisten Sportdisziplinen schießt man, sind die so justiert, dass man halt aufsitzend schießt. Das heißt, dass das Ziel, also der Kreis, dann die Mitte des Kreises, die man treffen will, über dieser Visierlinie liegt, also sozusagen oben drüber aufsitzt. Es gibt also Alternativ dazu, ist, dass man direkt rein hält. Das heißt, dass die direkt die Oberkante direkt ins Ziel zeigt. Aber es ist halt, das hat beim sportlichen Schießen sich gezeigt, dass man damit einfach besser trifft.
Wie hält man die Waffe?
Na ja, da kommt es auch auf die Disziplin und die Waffe an. Nach dem einhändig, zweihändig. Es gibt da auch ganz, ganz unterschiedliche Techniken. Aber grundsätzlich sollte man sie so halten, dass wenn man zittert, was man natürlich tut, dass man parallel zittert. So heißt es immer. Das heißt, was relativ unproblematisch ist für das Treffen, ist, wenn sich die Waffe als Ganzes nach rechts oder nach links bewegt, solange der Winkel gleich bleibt. Wenn man aber jetzt gewissermaßen die Waffe hin und her schwenkt, also wenn sich der Winkel ändert, führt das dann ganz schnell zu einer Riesenabweichung. Deswegen sollte man sich dann so hinstellen und die Muskeln dann so verspannen, dass, wenn es zu einem Zittern kommt, dieses Zittern eben nur parallel erfolgt.
Parallel zittern?
So. Gut. Und dann ist noch das Zweit wichtig, dass man sich dann gewöhnen muss, um zu treffen, dass man bei der Betätigung des Abzugs dort langsam die Kraft steigert und niemals bewusst abdrückt, also jetzt so peng, sondern man sitzt da und versucht linear die Abzugskraft im Finger zu steigern, bis völlig überraschend dann der Schuss losbricht. Also wenn man vorher weiß, wann sich der Schuss genau löst, hat man eigentlich schon Fehler gemacht. Das heißt, man muss sich vom Schuss überraschen lassen und dann trifft man auch ganz gut.
Was zu Beginn nicht so schwierig ist, ist man auf jeden Fall überrascht. Allein schon von dem unglaublichen Lärm und natürlich auch der Kraft, die so zurückschlägt. Wie du schon gesagt hast, ist ja unterschiedlich bei diesem Revolver. Da hat es schon ganz ordentlich... Man fliegt jetzt nicht hinten gegen die Scheibe, aber es ist so...
Unangenehm.
Man merkt schon, dass das Ding irgendwie ordentlich gegendrückt. Und auch natürlich ein bisschen nach oben fliegt. Und macht richtig Krach.
Ja, und es ist auch...
Aber es ist dann wirklich erstaunlich. Ich habe dann ja ein paar Mal geschossen. Ich war ja irgendwie erstaunt, dass ich dann auch... Ich glaube, ich habe sogar immer getroffen. Also ich habe immer das Blatt getroffen.
Ja, die Scheibe.
Nicht unbedingt immer jetzt so in die Mitte. Aber diese Präzision, von der du gesprochen hast, die war jetzt nicht so schwierig zu erzielen.
Naja, weil ich dir gesagt habe, wie man es richtig macht. Wenn ich dir das Ding einfach in die Hand gedrückt hätte und nichts dazu gesagt, dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich vergeblich nach einem Loch in der Scheibe.
Das kann gut sein.
Ich fand es auch erstaunlich damals, wie schlecht dann doch viele Leute eigentlich schießen. Wobei insgesamt in den letzten Jahren auch das Niveau deutlich besser geworden ist in Berlin. Generell hat es natürlich viel damit zu tun auch, dass vor der Wende gab es kaum Möglichkeiten, so mit größeren Kalibern zu schießen in Berlin.
In West-Berlin?
Ja, in West-Berlin, aber auch im Ostteil. In beiden Teilen gab es die Möglichkeit, sich irgendwelchen paramilitärischen Organisationen anzuschließen.
Oder militärische Organisationen. In der Bundeswehr, also in der Berliner Bundeswehr war es nicht so.
Ich rede jetzt vom sportlichen Schießen, was halt doch noch anders ist. Da hat sich dann schon gezeigt, dass das doch eine Weile gebraucht hat, bis allgemein vernünftige Schießleistungen da waren. Als ich mit meinen damals 32 Jahren oder so, als ich damit begonnen hatte, fühlte mich als einer der totalen Youngster. Dadurch, dass ich das dann auch jeden Tag eine Stunde gemacht habe, gehörte ich dann relativ schnell zur Familie.
Nicht nur zur Familie, sondern ich war dann halt erstaunt.
Ich dachte früher, man sieht das von Olympia und den ganzen Schützen, die dort stehen und irgendwelche übermenschlichen metaphysischen Dinge tun, zu denen man wahrscheinlich niemals in der Lage wäre. Aber das in bestimmten Disziplinen kann man schon mit zwei, drei Jahren Training ungefähr schaffen, bis zu den deutschen Meisterschaften vorzudrängen. Da bin ich immer bislang knapp an der Qualifikation dann vorbei geschrammt, aber bei den Landesmeisterschaften war es eigentlich relativ unproblematisch, immer unter die besten Szenen des Landes zu kommen. Also das ist etwas, was man sich durchaus als realistisches Ziel setzen. Aber wie gesagt, die Konkurrenz wird auch besser. Und es ist sicherlich auch so, dass am Anfang in den ersten Jahren natürlich die Faszination doch größer ist. Irgendwann wird es dann doch so ein bisschen zur Routine, wenn man merkt, dass man irgendwo an seiner Leistungsspitze irgendwann angekommen ist.
Wir haben ja jetzt nur über Faustfeuerwaffen geredet. Das ist ja jetzt eigentlich auch das einzige, womit du dich wirklich beschäftigt hast, oder? Also es gibt ja noch Gewehre.
Ja, ich habe in der Anfangszeit dann auch mit Gewehren geschossen. Aber zum einen ist das Problem, dass man einen größeren Stand braucht. Also es gibt deutlich weniger Schießstände, wo man mit Gewehren schießen kann. Da muss man immer weiter rausfahren. Also innerstädtische Gewehrstände sind ganz schwierig bis nicht existent.
Was brauchen die denn für spezielle Anforderungen?
Na, du brauchst erstmal größere Entfernungen, so ist es die eine Sache. Also viele Gewehrdisziplinen sind auch über 100 oder 200 Meter Entfernung. Die Größe muss man erstmal haben und dann ist die Geschossenergie auch noch mal höher bei Gewehren. Das heißt, da muss dann auch noch eine entsprechende Beschaffenheit da sein. Also das war so der eine Grund. Dann ist die Munition noch mal ein Tick teurer und dann Aufbewahrung und Transport der Waffen. Also mir waren die Dinge einfach zu groß.
Ja klar, da reicht dann ein kleiner Tresor auch nicht mehr aus, da brauchst du schon einen leuchtenden Waffenschrank.
Ja, das waren so Dinge, also ich fand ja Handfeuerwaffen einfach interessanter. Also vielleicht noch eine Sache, auch immer die Mythen, also Durchschlagskraft war noch so ein Ding, was wir noch nicht erwähnt hatten beim Thema Zielballistik. Also hier jetzt diese typischen Handfeuerwaffen sind in der Lage, noch so Bleche, also von 5 bis 8 Millimeter Bleche zu durchschlagen. Das ist so, aber dann die Grenze. Also ein 10 Millimeter Stahlblech, also 1 Zentimeter bis von der Faustfeuerwaffe schon nicht mehr zu durchdringen, selbst wenn die Kugel gerade...
Nach welcher Distanz? Mit welcher Distanz?
Na Distanz gut, jetzt auch aus nächster Nähe nicht. Also jetzt ein 10 Millimeter Stahlblech, es ist halt relativ sicher, so gegen alle Arten von Faustfeuerwaffen. Da muss man dann eventuell mit entsprechenden Kriegswaffen oder mit Gewehren, hat man da vielleicht auch noch Gelegenheit. Allerdings das Karosserieblech zum Beispiel bietet relativ wenig Widerstand. So mit 0,8 oder 1 Millimeter kann das durchaus gut sein. Also wie gesagt, dass man so 5 bis 8 Karosseriebleche hintereinander durchschlägt. Also da Schutz zu suchen. Die andere Sache, weswegen man auch... Also solche Kugeln fliegen halt, sind zum einen recht durchschlagskräftig. Also in Altbauten auch, können die halt dann auch schon mal so eine Geschossdecke oder so eine Wand durchschlagen. Wenn die nicht gerade aus Stein besteht, aber dann fliegen die Dinger auch einfach unglaublich weit. Also selbst so eine Pistolenkugel kann auf einem Kilometer Entfernung noch tödlich sein. Deswegen bietet es sich halt auch überhaupt nicht an, jetzt für Polizisten bei Einsätzen irgendwo jemanden in der Stadt hinterher zu schießen.
Weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man irgendwas trifft, doch sehr hoch ist.
Ja, also wie gesagt, die fliegen halt dann einfach weit und sind einfach auf weiten Strecken noch echt gefährlich.
Was verwenden denn Polizisten für Waffen?
Ja gut, aktuell weiß ich gar nicht, was jetzt so die aktuellen Dienstwaffen sind. Wobei das sicherlich auch noch von Bundesland zu Bundesland teilweise verschieden ist. Aber als Kaliber ist halt generell bei Behörden und auch beim Militär 9 mm Parabellum ist halt eines der beliebtesten Kaliber.
Was heißt das Parabellum?
Tja, das hat sich auch damals irgendwie der Designer ausgedacht, es ist wahrscheinlich irgendwie über den Krieg oder so oder jenseits des Krieges, ich weiß es nicht oder vielleicht auch eine Anspielung auf Parabel. So es ist einfach nur, wenn du so willst, eine technische Markennahme, Windows und weil die halt so verbreitet sind, das war für mich so auch der Ausschlag. Also man muss sich dann typischerweise als Sportschütze auf zwei Kaliber beschränken bei der Berechtigung. Ich sag mal, mit entsprechender, man wirklich viel schießt und Bedarf hat, geht auch mehr. Aber das ist dann halt sehr mühsam. Standard sind halt so zwei Kaliber. Und meistens nimmt man dann eine Pistole und einen Revolver. Dann hat man so immer beide Arten, weil es doch unterschiedlich ist, wie sich das anfühlt. Und dann ist es immer so eine Frage, was kostet die Munition natürlich? Und da hat man halt mit 9 mm Para vergleichsweise günstige Munition. Jetzt für einen Großkaliber und mit den 357ern auch. Also es ist so ein bisschen auch ein Kostenkompromiss gewesen. Ja, und ansonsten gibt es aber also bei Sportschützen sehr beliebte Pistolen im Kaliber 44. Das ist dann sogenannte Colt 1911A. Das ist halt diese typische amerikanische Armeepistole, die halt im Jahre 1911 entworfen wurde. Sieht dafür, dass sie von 1911 ist, recht modern aus. Und die ist so, das ist auch das Sportschützen-Standard-Modell, natürlich nicht in der alten Militärvariante, sondern die ist tausendfach nachgebaut in allen möglichen Edelvarianten. Bei Revolvern kann man ja noch auf 45 Magnum gehen, aber da ist man dann auch gleich immer bei der Munition. Zum Teil ist es dann doppelt bis dreifach so teuer. Hier muss man schon rechnen, je nach Kalibermunitionsart, so zwischen 30 Cent und 1,50 Euro pro Schuss.
Kein billiges Hobby auf jeden Fall. Was kostet eine Waffe?
Eine Pistole hier? Ja, das kommt auch drauf an. Die SIG P210 kennen gerade nicht den Marktpreis, aber ich würde sagen, in der Gegend von 1000 Euro ungefähr.
Und der Revolver bewegt sich noch nicht so sehr?
Nein, der lag auch in der Gegend, aber die Pistole war nur deswegen so günstig, weil sie halt schon 40 Jahre alt war.
Also Fabrik neu, gut, müssen wir mal nach Grün los.
Ja, also zwischen 500 und 1000 Euro muss man für eher die 1000 als die 500 schon anlegen. Wobei man sagt, man ist nicht gezwungen, sich eine eigene Waffe zu kaufen. Die meisten Vereine haben Vereinswaffen, die man sich dann auch leihen kann, beziehungsweise mit denen man am Anfang sowieso schießen muss, solange man keine eigenen hat. Ja, vielleicht bleibt noch zu erwähnen, Gutes wissen aber auch meisten, selbst wenn man dann die Waffen hat, heißt es nicht, dass man jetzt dann mit einer geladenen Waffe im Halfter durch die Gegend laufen darf, sondern das darf man allenfalls zuhause, in der eigenen Wohnung, aber nicht draußen, sobald man das Privatgrundstück verlässt, darf man sie transportieren, das heißt ungeladen, in einem Koffer weggeschlossen, am besten im Kofferraum des Fahrzeugs.
Würdest du denn sagen, dass der gesetzgeberische Rahmen zum Besitz von Waffen, so wie er jetzt in Deutschland ist, angemessen ist, ausreichend ist?
Es ist eine schwierige Frage, was ist angemessen ausreichend. Es ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert. Natürlich empfindet man für einen selbst viele Dinge durchaus als Gängelei oder unnötig scharf manche gesetzlichen Regelungen oder auch sinnlos. Auf der anderen Seite möchte man, gerade wenn man weiß, was dazugehört, die Dinge sicher zu handhaben, möchte man auch nicht, dass jeder Idiot irgendwie damit rumrennt. Also unterm Strich gesehen, würde ich sagen, ist die Situation, denke ich, in Deutschland soweit in Ordnung. In England beispielsweise wurde nach diesem schrecklichen Anschlag da in dem Kindergarten, glaube ich, wurden ja sämtliche Waffen, also wurde privater Waffenbesitz, komplett verboten. Ja, also England ist sozusagen das Gegenteil-Gegenstück nochmal. Da wurden dann, das war ziemlich durchaus auch bitter für ja Sportschützen oder auch Sammler, wurden halt komplett, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Millionen Waffen eingesammelt, wobei natürlich sie nicht einfach eingezogen werden konnten, sondern der Staat die abkaufen musste. Das heißt, da ist irgendwie, da mussten mehrere Milliarden Pfund aufgewendet werden, um dort quasi den privaten Waffenbesitzer zu...
Aber das ist jetzt schon abgeschlossen. Das heißt, es gibt sozusagen keinen einzigen legalen Waffenbesitzer in...
Ja, also kaum. Es gibt vielleicht ganz wenig Ausnahmen für irgendwelche...
Was machen dann diese Sportler?
Es gibt keine mehr dort. Die können dann ins Ausland fahren und im Ausland trainieren. Da wurde sozusagen der gesamte... Ja, also da gibt es halt Waffen nur noch bei der Polizei und ansonsten illegale...
Ich meine gerade, England ist ja nun auch ein Land der Jagd. Ganz Britannien eigentlich.
Wie ist es bei den Jagdwaffen?
Wahrscheinlich nur noch Adlige.
Ja, das könnte gut sein.
Auweia.
Ja, also von daher muss ich sagen, ist das halbwegs ausgewogen, die Situation. Also man muss schon durch, ja, also man muss, wie gesagt, bestimmte Bedingungen erfüllen, wo dann, ich sag mal, viele Idioten, zumindest von denen man nicht möchte, dass die Waffenbesitzer halt nicht die Ausdauer besitzen, um so weit zu kommen. Oder dass, wenn die schon mal auffällig geworden sind...
Ich meine, vielleicht noch mal kurz zu Britannien. Ich meine, wenn es jetzt kein privater Waffen besitzt, das ist ja dann auch quasi der Tod aller Waffenhändler gewesen. Also es gibt auch keine Waffenläden mehr, die sind alle jetzt pleite oder was. Also die hat jetzt den Staat dann ausgekauft oder was.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, wie sie das eben, naja gut, es gibt dann halt noch, wie gesagt, vielleicht ein bisschen Jagdwaffen und ein bisschen Polizei, Behörden. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie sie es dann mit den Wachdiensten oder ähnlichem handhaben. Also es gibt sicherlich noch eine ganze Reihe von Ausnahmen.
Davon ist die USA wahrscheinlich noch weit entfernt.
Ja, da sind sie da eher auf der anderen übertriebenen Seite. Wobei man auch sagen muss, dass der Sport dort doch extrem hoch entwickelt ist. In Deutschland ist auch das, was an sportlichen Wettkämpfen und Disziplinen zulässig ist, sehr eingeschränkt im Vergleich zu dem, was in den USA geht. Im Prinzip ist in Deutschland fast die Grenze erreicht beim ich stehe halt auf dem Stand und schieße auf eine Scheibe. So irgendwie mit der Waffe irgendwo rumzurennen auf einem Parcours oder ähnliches, das ist dann schon... Da gibt es auch das sogenannte IPSC-Schießen, ist alles, also auch in Deutschland da. Ja, das ist dann auch ein... So ein Wettbewerb? Wettbewerb, wo man eben, wie gesagt, auf einem Parcours, auf Ziele, die plötzlich auftauchen, also mehr so eine Art Sportart, wo so ein bisschen mehr Gefechtssituationen simuliert wird sportlich gesehen, wo es darum geht, um halt schnelle Zielwechsel. Und das ist alles in Deutschland komplett untersagt. Es ist auch verboten, außer irgendwie beim Militär und der Polizei, auf Zielscheiben zu schießen, die Menschen repräsentieren. Also menschliche Körperformen oder so ist auch verboten.
Heißt, in Britannien dürfte jetzt wahrscheinlich Paintball einen großen Auftrieb verspüren? Könnte ich mir so vorstellen. Keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich so ist. Und bei ist es nochmal ein anderes Thema. Ja, dieses Thema haben wir glaube ich zu Ende gebracht, oder? Haben wir noch irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen?
Es gibt noch endlos viel zu sagen, aber ich denke, das Wichtigste ist abgebetet worden. Und ich dachte vielleicht, ansonsten kann ich nur sagen, wen es interessiert, der Sport, einfach mal gucken, was gibt es denn für Schützenvereine. Oder es gibt da auch riesige Unterschiede von Land zu Land, von Bundesland zu Bundesland, wie das dort gehandhabt wird, speziell wie lange man braucht, um mit großkalibrigen Waffen überhaupt schießen zu dürfen. Ein Kleinkaliber Luftgewehr ist relativ unproblematisch.
Das heißt, im Wesentlichen alles Landesgesetze, Landesverordnungen?
Ja, es gibt auch Bundeseinheit. Das Waffengesetz selbst ist halt Bundesgesetz, aber so wie das jetzt tatsächlich in der Praxis gehandhabt wird mit den Erlaubnisrechten, was die Vereine dürfen und wie viele Hürden einem da in den Weg gelegt werden, ist sogar von Stadt zu Stadt ganz unterschiedlich. Ansonsten finde ich, ist es eine interessante Traditionssportart auf jeden Fall und ich finde, es macht Spaß und ist aber zumindest in Deutschland nach meinem Gefühl im Aussterben begriffen. Viele werden sich darüber sicher freuen, wobei, wie gesagt, dann doch in Migranten hätten diese Sportart dann doch gerne ausgeübt wird.
Okay, Pavel, dann sage ich Danke für die Ausführung und ich hoffe, für euch war auch was dabei bei einem Technikausflug der besonderen Art. Hier bei Chaosradio Express. Ich freue mich wie immer über Feedback in unserem Blog chaosradio.ccc.de, bietet euch die Podcast-Blog. chaosradio.ccc.de bietet das Blog zur Sendung und da könnt ihr irgendwie einen Kommentar versenken. Wenn es was ganz Wichtiges gibt, lese ich auch gerne E-Mail. chaosradio.ccc.de Ja, ich würde sagen, das war's. Wir sagen schön Tschüss. Und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.